dr anthony fauci is president biden's
chief medical advisor and the top
infectious disease doctor at the
national institutes of health
he joins us now for further conversation
dr fauci always good to see you
help us we need a reality check here we
heard the president say last night that
he
thinks that the vaccine will be
available by the end of july
i've also heard you say it could be by
the end of april do you think that's
still possible
no i think closer to what the president
had said when we were talking about
april we were hoping that when you say
available you're talking about
to anybody yeah beyond the
um layered uh priorities you know the 1a
1b1c and then you get to the point where
you say now anybody
who's anybody can wind up getting a
vaccine we were hoping
that it would be by the end of april but
what has happened is that the doses that
we were expecting uh earlier from
the j and j likely will not be available
for another couple of months after that
the ultimate total amount of doses that
j and j will get us we're pretty
confident that we're going to get the
100 million doses
by the end of june the beginning of july
and i believe that's the reason why when
the president was saying available
by july it was in tune with the fact
that we will get those doses that we
were promised
and i'm sure we'll get them by that time
so i think the dates now
coincide pretty well okay july i know i
like what you said about
where anybody and anybody can get it you
know that there are no guidelines that
we all get the vaccine as soon as we can
there seems to be a difference
in how this every state seems to handle
it differently do we need to have a
uniform process
because you know i hear reports of
vaccines being thrown out i hear reports
of
people showing up and getting it because
they have leftover doses
what can we do to get it on track and
get it going smoothly yeah
you know gail that is that is an issue
that's been around for a long time
because on the one hand
you want to respect the ability and the
right of states who know their own
situation
well to make their own decisions about
that
and there's a reluctance always to
dictate from above but the point that
you make is a good point
there should be some sort of consistency
not necessarily identical
from state to state but i think what
you're referring to is what i myself
am seeing when i ask around is that the
the capability of a person in one
category
to get a vaccine differs greatly from
state to state
hopefully that will smooth out as we get
more vaccine doses you know the
interesting thing gail
the the cure of all of this is when the
supply demand gap
closes because right now that the demand
far out see uh exceeds the supply
as we get into the later months april
may june and july as you were mentioning
just a little bit ago i think those kind
of discrepancies and difficulties are
going to disappear
hey dr fauci it's tony i want to shift
topics slightly to schools the president
is saying that
younger children in lower schools could
be back in the classrooms by spring
what's behind that could what needs to
happen for spring to be the timeline
you know i'm i'm not do you know tony i
i don't want to try and read his mind
what he said about could
i mean i i what i think he meant and
again
obviously the final decision will be up
to him what i think he meant
is that if you look at the cdc
guidelines
and the things that were recommended
about how to make
their entry and the maintenance of kids
in school particularly at that age
are the things that were delineated in
the cdc guidelines
and i believe what the president meant
is that if we adhere to those guidelines
that we could get the kids back to
school in the date that he mentioned
so i think that's quite compatible with
what i just said
that he's he referred a couple of times
to the cdc guidelines about trying to
make it
safe for the children and safe for the
teachers and other people in the
educational system quick question about
the other people in the educational
system
as part of the cdc guidelines teachers
are not considered
must be vaccinated personnel in order
for schools to reopen
what do you say to teachers who say hold
on that's a condition for me i'm worried
you know i i think you have to rethink
that i think if you were going to say
that every single teacher needs to be
vaccinated
before you get back to school i believe
quite frankly tony that that's a
non-workable situation
i think teachers should absolutely be
priority
among those who we consider essential
personnel
and you should try and get as many
teachers as you possibly can
vaccinated as quickly as you possibly
can but to make it a scene quan on
that you don't open a school until every
teacher is vaccinated
i think is not workable and probably
most of the teachers
would agree with that you want to put a
good effort to get as many as you can as
quickly as you can
but you don't want to essentially have
nobody in school
until all the teachers get vaccinated so
dr vaucci you're now a verb i know you
heard about it i
now have a new dating requirement in
addition to no smoking no nose rings
no fouching somebody who doesn't take it
seriously
so what do you think about being adverb
and what's your best dating advice for
people trying to date in coven
since you've dated you've got a lovely
wife but what's your dating advice
gail i have to tell you that is one
subject that i absolutely am staying
away from
as much as i love you i'm not going
there a rare i don't know
i love you too dr somebody sent me a
hand puppet a dr fauci i'd like to send
it to you
you'll get a kick out of it thank you
sir thank you always good to see you
ahead yes
thank you you're welcome